electric
coupling module you said it was nothing
serious when i came in
you said you were sure
guess i was wrong can always look for
another shop where they won't ask a lone
nomad why he's hugging the border
that's fine step aside what
got any idea what to do
i'm gonna bypass the coupling and rig a
hot wire
compressor run on and on
did anyone ask your opinion
okay let's see what happens
it's like i was telling you
not shabby at all questions how long
it'll last you
it'll get me to night city i figured
something else out there
right
antenna on this heap don't seem like it
packs a punch not liable to hear much
you don't say
[Music]
hey mike didn't know you had a customer
uh rolled in a few hours passed i i
thought
he at least called in don't you swear to
mine we're gonna hash it out
don't you know you owe the sheriff a
word when you pay his town a visit
to tell him what's brought you here even
over a cup of coffee
my mistake i hadn't planned on stopping
a failed coupling forced my hand
yeah always some failure high in
mistakes
name's andrew jones probably heard of me
i can't say that i have
served in spec ops during the last war
silver shoguns bring any bells
if you have a problem i'm willing to
hear it
let me tell you what my problem is
nothing
boils my blood like a [ __ ] strain
where'd your clan pitch cam
there is no clan there is no camp i'm
here alone
ain't buying it nomads always stick to
their packs
my family's in pieces that's why i'm
headed for night city
makes you an outcast among outcasts
sure as hell hope you'll be on your way
before long
i heard this place is famous for its
hospitality
glad to see it wasn't just rumors you
are damn right
when people come along who know how to
behave
i sold broadcasting comms tower my way
in my antenna is down
and i need to radio someone what you
need is to hightail it out of here
without another word
ain't got no mind to see you drifting
around these parts
got it
you like the sound of your voice don't
you what's that drifter
what are you on about nothing nothing at
all
[Music]
hello come in come in
ah raised you finally willie mccoy
it's good to hear your voice fee
wish i could say the same
i need your help one last time
one last time again i have to find the
client with my payload
but i don't know where he is
right place right time you were there
my car gave out the electric coupling
it's a miracle i made it here
maybe the client left a message could
you check for me
hmm sure
last time though i mean client's name
jackie wells
huh actually left a message he's waiting
on a farm
flicking you the globe data thanks
willie i owe you one
you do just don't get yourself killed
and don't call again
all right
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
oh i was worried i'd have to turn to
farming
yeah sure hope you're here for me
i believe i am are you name's jackie
wells
v seems you have cargo that needs to be
moved
oh where i'm from you share a bit about
your soul before you talk biz
huh it's kind of like a custom
or just good manners you know you're a
man a principal
you need a backbone cabron at least
you'll have that left when they've taken
everything else
why don't we start with you then nc
native right here
got haywood in my blood i've never been
to nc
that doesn't mean much to me so imagine
a place where everyone's like your bro
or sis
or a distant cousin at least i think i
understand
you don't have to like each other but
it's family that's haywood
that and everyone's backing iron
and you i guess one could say i'm from
my own haywood
you and me we're gonna get along fine
the cargo what's inside
you sleep better the less you know got
no idea myself
and that's a good thing you don't know
what we ain't to smuggle
these are stolen corporate goods stolen
oh
some gunk lost the crane some other gunk
found it passed it on
now it's here you know butterfly effect
or whatever
and there's no one looking for this
crate ain't no problem if they look
only a problem if they find it before it
crosses the border no
let's load it in the car oh
started thinking you might not come i
got held up
and you weren't exactly easy to find i
decided to lay low you know
the sheriff looked like one grouchy
[ __ ]
yep
what a fat ass
so we headed out
you have to manifest from the transport
of course i do
but the fixer didn't give you the job
deeds
he did i was just making sure
listen friend we're more professionals
hey
hey you uh sure you've both contraband
before
why are you nervous me
well uh maybe a little
hey border crossing up ahead what now
nothing they'll scan us to check our
papers
okay i'll do the talking
please direct your vehicle to the
inspection area
remain in your vehicle the security
check will begin shortly
i got a real bad feeling about this
hand me the manifest don't need to see
it grab these
let me see it's marked l-a
perfect what's that mean lost an arrival
it means the cargo is flagged as to be
lost as soon as you cross the border
so they know we're smuggling they're
about to find out
the owner of the vehicle in the
inspection area will report
for further questioning
what now we want the customs officer to
turn a blind eye to our dubious docus
we'll need a sweetener do you have the
credit chip with the bribe
oh yeah
forgot about that
right you forgot
i'll keep the engine running in case of
a cock-up
do that
if you're armed place your weapon here
now please report to room number two
i know the rules everything's there it
might be
it might not be we'll see
hmm what are you transporting
it's all in there
everything there's one additional
enclosure to the manifest
ah yes remind me you drive for which
nomad clan
none no clan i drive for myself
bold and none too wise
you know whenever i see someone like you
i'm oh so grateful not to be on that
side of the table
the feeling's mutual go on now
your associate's waiting for you in the
car
don't forget to take your personal items
be careful with that toy and welcome to
night city
those little shits imagine night city is
some kind of paradise
what can you do young naive
which is just a euphemism for ignorant
what happened in there i'll tell you
soon
we need to get out of here yeah okay
[Music]
you're gonna tell me what happened back
there
let's say i have a bad feeling about
this oh
happened a lot to you rarely
smelling trouble around the bend drive
jackie just drive
someone's coming our way this does not
look good
stop your vehicle immediately let's get
out of here on it
you are transporting contraband that is
corporate property
i repeat stop the car
damn
so
gotta keep moving
be watching
keep driving can't stop here
place looks deserted gonna stop here
i need to sort out a few things before
we go on
i almost tagged our asses not what you
call smuggling
gado was supposed to go smooth
no problems calm down
sometimes these things happen this what
kind of [ __ ] happens border security
tipped off the corporation that we have
their cargo
what's the deal with these borderlines
flipping us a finger as they [ __ ]
please
with no consequences he took risk he
assumed we didn't have a clan back in us
and he was right
so what now we've crossed the border
now you pay me and we go our separate
ways
i ain't gonna lie i'm a bit light
i can't pay you now i have something for
you once i collect my scrap for this
corporal crap we're carrying
huh and you just figured i would sit by
patiently
actually i wasn't gonna pay you at all
it's just gonna bust
ass disappear as soon as we crossed over
but
you're all right
i appreciate the honesty yeah thanks
so what's next
now we take a peek inside
open it
oh [ __ ] it says arasaka on the crate
we are robbing some heavy hitters maybe
we'll make some heavy money
a real iguana a uh lesser angelian i
think
lesser and till what yeah what's the
thing on tv about them
went extinct like 30 years ago they're
from the lesser antilles
you come a long way my scaly friend
you think he can make some money on it
sure
i think it'll make us happy us yeah
partner
we'll go half season any decent fixer
will find a loaded gog interested in a
rare gem like this
it's kind of a shame though i always
wanted a pen
got the name manny all thought out
hey by the way you uh got any plans for
what you'll be doing in night city
i don't have any plans i spent the last
years traveling between states with my
nomad family
i'll probably be waiting for you
somewhere eh no
we decided to go our separate ways i
must be tough huh
i haven't no one to go back to but don't
you worry
let me help you find dicks you got to
live somewhere
it's important to have people you can
turn to you know like uh
family maybe you'll find your own down
in night city
thanks much appreciate it hey come on
it's nothing
you got chemistry you and me be a crying
shame to waste it
partner hey oh
cuddly little [ __ ] okay partner
time to grab the lizard and scurry out
of here
[Music]
me you there
yeah yeah
i'm here you all right
fine just needed a breather
it sounded like you blew your guts
airlock yeah
i barfed it's just dressed
[Music]
we had a leak my boss called dragged me
in because we had to intervene
everyone at night city hq is on edge but
no way you're [ __ ] right
you're the one who fixes other people's
[ __ ] jackie
if you work in our soccer counter intel
you're always [ __ ]
don't worry about me i'll manage on my
own
yes you want something
2071 arasaka security forces prevent
mass riots in san francisco saving the
city from certain ruin
2074 an arasaka
[Music]
god held up but i'll be right there
[ __ ] frankfurt
that abernathy [ __ ] will probably dump
it in our laps
hanging up i'll be in my office you
hurry up
militech hit three of ours now we're
evacuating the rest of our facilities
mr jenkins asked he's in his office
it's been ages it's me frank
we met during ice fall east coast
remember
i didn't know you're a night city have
you been
ah you know how it is a week ago i was
still in cape town
i heard you're encounter intel must have
a [ __ ] show on your hands right now
after frankfurt
jenkins is your lead right is he what
everyone says he is
what's everyone say about jenkins that
he's effective
like any psychopath apparently he's gone
a little crazier lately
hey he's in a tough spot the director
was supposed to green light his
promotion when the japanese arrived
she stabbed him in the back instead
and you who do you work under abernathy
she's really good came up with the whole
cape town ploy on her own
abernathy the [ __ ] who burned my boss
on the promotion to spec ops director
you know how it is things happen yeah
they do indeed tell me about the op in
cape town
operation cargo you know about it
arming local conflicts in africa i
didn't know that was you
it was me we dumped crates full of
rifles into the ocean
they had to be pulled out using borrowed
fishing boats
same old circus but hey that's how wars
are won
listen sorry uh in a bit of a rush right
now
we'll talk another time okay sure sure
good seeing you again
[Music]
emergency protocols active system
security confirmed
please enter the antechamber
visitor authorization granted are you
online
[Music]
have a seat beep be right with you we
have to handle this voting issue before
we lose our bases
in the sea of clouds they're about to
begin what's the situation
yeah just as we thought
you know what to do start now
[Music]
director abernathy i watched the vote
what the hell was that a deep clean
after the [ __ ] frankfurt dumped on us as
we agreed
i got rid of the problem i told you to
resolve the problem not
massacre the european space council do
you understand what the cover-up will
cost
we would have lost the license now we
gained a week that's a win
path of least resistance always no
nuance
has you written all over it we're not
done talking about this
i hate that [ __ ] i always have
[Music]
always meaning how long before night
city we worked on an assignment in osaka
two years of subterfuge she spent them
digging a trap for me
when she became director of spec ops
that's when she finally shoved me in it
now she's holding a gun to my head to
make sure i don't try anything
but she won't pull the trigger because
she needs me
i do what she doesn't have the guts to
do
divide and conquer effective strategy
effective
what would you do in my position
you have to defend yourself remind
abernathy you're not her doormat
you're right smack her once but hard
she'll respect you
seems we see eye to eye on this issue
take this
a data shard proof of my trust
go on take it
it's what i've collected over the past
weeks biometrics
trauma team card names of her closest
associates
driver chief of security her
lover's husband everything use it
and make sure abernathy won't be a
problem anymore
you said it i need to defend myself
if anyone finds out we even talked about
this
i'll go down with you that's true
but everyone knows you only made it to
where you are thanks to me
so it's not like they could ever believe
you played no part in it
what'll happen if i refuse
don't ask stupid questions this isn't
a request v we seem to understand each
other
take this too
craigship transactions are traceable
paper disappears as soon as you spend it
what can i say use this money only
find the right people for the job no
corporate affiliation
and for the core task use someone you
know
inside out are we clear yeah
i think we're clear good in that case
i'll await your report and good luck
with it
i have my av waiting outside it's yours
to use
and don't disappoint me
i need an analysis of the legislative
procedures for lunar based licenses
i have those reports you asked for
i don't have the time to send them my
way
[Music]
hey b you alive i'll stink
in the viper pit
viper pit couldn't have said it better
you in some trouble not yet right now i
just need a soul i can trust
that kind of sounded like a yes meet me
at lizzie's
either in an hour [ __ ]
the world's going to tear us away
access granted they won't know it for
long
i need your stamp on something it's
possible one of our assets was exposed
is it frankfurt again no different issue
local tell me quick version
our agent at biotechnica suspects they
might be on to him
they recently granted him red security
clearance that's top
he's been fishing for dirt but it's been
slow your point
they're clean like we run orphanages
clean
bleach server clean we suspect they
flagged him and are feeding him phony
data
should we green light exfil or let him
keep looking
projected risks limited threat to life
not biotechnica style blackmails
possible
leveraged against false accusations in
the media the guy has kids
he'd crack pull them out but calmly
don't raise any eyebrows
otherwise they'll catch on jenkins will
be livid
i'll handle jenkins understood
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
so
so
please provide your destination
bring up district analytics increased
ncpd presence and activity has been
reported in haywood
no official statement has been
forthcoming
intercepted radio communications suggest
maxtac has been sent to the area
a widespread power failure has been
reported in santo domingo
all other districts exhibit activity
within expected parameters
destination lizzie's bar noted
[Music]
a conference of the european space
council screeched to a grisly halt
following a failure in a neural
stabilization system
five european space council members are
dead
while three remain in critical condition
authorities are still looking into what
might have caused this shocking incident
the council members were all wearing
biotechnica provided devices
the corporation's representatives have
as yet refused to comment
our reporter is on the scene we'll have
updates on developments
as they come to life stay with n54 news
for the latest
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello v yes we weren't scheduled to
connect till the end of the week
quantified satori received notification
of a somewhat troubling
biometric reading i felt i should call
is everything in order
i'm dealing with a temporary nuisance
nothing you should worry about
just think back to our last session the
neuromotor relaxation exercises
three times a day they'll soothe and
lift your spirit
i know this sure okay see you later
no designated landing site has been
detected at the destination
find a spot close to the bar as close as
you can [ __ ] procedures
initiating landing sequence based on new
parameters
[Music]
we have arrived at your destination
[ __ ] your problem psycho suit
this look like a land impaired to you
could have [ __ ] crushed us
out of my way what who the [ __ ] are you
to say that to me
our soccer counter intel we done here
couldn't use the front door like
everyone else
listen i'm in a hurry and you're wasting
my time
i'm gonna keep an eye on you
yeah yeah welcome to lizzie's
[Music]
what the [ __ ] i'm just getting started
yeah got something to say
[Music]
now come here often do you it's good to
see you come on
now sit down and tell me what's good
your shorts and or not it's good to see
you too jack
how you been i got sparks flying between
the valentino boys and maelstrom
eddie's there for the taking as long as
you don't get flatlined
you know how it is can't complain but
we ain't here to shoot the [ __ ] about me
let me hear about this problem of yours
jackie before i start this stays between
us
i'm serious this thing
it could ruin me so could i
you do realize who you're talking to
right the guy who's done this before
remember what happened in mexico at the
border
i peeped one word i know you saved my
ass
i've worried about the cartels that
gotten out but it didn't and this won't
either
that's why you came to see dear old
[Music]
jackie
data shard take it
[Music]
what do you think won't come cheap it'll
have to be done on the sly
no trail hard eddies only got the money
full crew job for sure techy maybe two
a runner with a gold-plated brain and a
driver with wheels from hell
not to mention the solo huh
the piece i'm missing that what you need
from me
my trigger finger to zero this lady
delicate situation i know that's why i
need somebody i can trust
this ain't no delicate situation and
it's a hit job
plain and simple you know how arasaka
operates
or okay maybe you don't this isn't a
professional request i can refuse
but i can and i am
and you should too now
what do you say we liquor up and talk
life
[Music]
double tequila with grenadine and lime
nothing better for drowning nerves
to this was that a toast what the hell
does that even mean
you raise a glass to your mama your
hermana
to the mamasita you'll meet at the bar
but this
doesn't say a damn thing
to this
this job and all the rest of that
corporal [ __ ]
you know what it is
[Music]
been saying it all along soldiers sold
to those arasaka [ __ ]
today they got you to zero somebody
tomorrow they'll get somebody else to
zero you
think i have a choice if i refuse they
take
everything and leave me nothing i will
let them
they'll also take the fist they got
gripping your balls
i don't know about you but i'm pretty
picky about who i let touch my balls
and saburo and his matones oh they
definitely do not make the cut
maybe someday but for now i'm still well
within the reach
you'll always be within reach always be
hey you lost got a problem
v is that right
[Music]
you're from arasaka hq is there a
problem are you here about frankfurt
we're here for you jenkins assigned you
a task today
you'll share all the details with us
name and department again didn't quite
catch it first time around
[ __ ] how you feeling pretty sharp dive
huh
your access to company networks is
hereby revoked
in two minutes any company cybernetics
in your possession will cease
functioning
give us the data you received from
jenkins this will conclude termination
procedures
how the hell did you find out that is
not your concern
data now
information is on the shard smart choice
we done with the formalities
yes but i think abernathy would gladly
up our fee for riding her of a piece of
rot like you
stand up you're coming with us come on
move
us i think you fellows might have
forgotten just how far from home you are
not sure this body was your style let
alone a healthy option
that a threat you start shooting
maybe we join in huh before you know it
somebody might die today we have what we
came for
it'll do for now
[Music]
that's one there
v how you feel you all right
i i can't breathe
need help no no it's just
withdrawal syndrome sort of
i think they cut off my hormone
regulators
biomine and sad analysis system
body's got to adjust hey hey
should i get you to a ripper or i guess
maybe drama team's on its way
tt policy's gone jack so are my biochem
controllers
company pad i mean they seized my bank
account
not frozen seized jesus
these [ __ ] move fast you sure you
feel okay though
i mean give me a minute
get my [ __ ] together
that that'd be that jack
just lost control of my life completely
i'd say you got it back you couldn't say
no to him
so they said it to you this is a turn
for the better
you'll see besides
you haven't lost everything
about to say i i still have a friend
that's sweet
no dumb ass you still got that wad for
the hit job don't you
probably some fat ass chunk of cha-chang
just right for a new start
that's right fool buckle up
hey you hearing all right
don't look so high v
your new life it starts now
a little anesthesia
[Music]
oh [ __ ] everything chill man
some bastard tried to mug me i handled
it
oh local guy you really think somebody
local
try to mug me pepe
listen v i got a problem serious this
time
come on spin it what is it now
it's a cork i him
don't pay by tomorrow said he bust my
legs
he don't joke about that stuff got
cartel's in his corner
you're in it with kirk every man woman
and rat in haywood knows he's a [ __ ]
shark
my bro jumped the joint deserve the
hero's welcome
i know i felt comfy
you ever gonna get wise pepe
please tell me your brother's doing all
right uh
doing his thing you know so
can you help
i'll talk to kirk but then you're gonna
owe me one minute
you're saving my life
[Music]
[Music]
okay
what you need pepe
asked me to talk you up what he too shot
a hand over the yetis himself
uh tell him i don't fight not yet
cut him some slack will you you pay
just need some more time
do i look like a priest that runs a
charity to you
you borrow eddie's you gotta pay him
back with interest
it's common [ __ ] knowledge you
suggesting i let a flaky [ __ ] who can't
keep a deal off the hook
no you let him off because it's me
asking
you know me i'm a man of the bids so i
need to know
what i get out of it transactions go two
ways
i get that i'll owe you a favor
got a nova idea already
what's this grab a look
cream right there on the page only four
of them in nc as of now
one rayfield regional director two
mayor ryan three a rental service
uh-huh and four number four will belong
to my client
just as soon as you clap it for me that
is
i do this pepe's dead is squared
of course i'm a man of my word you know
that
whole thing simple you swipe the ray
field for me
i clear pepe's account even toss in a
cut for you i'm such a nice guy
my man rick works a parking structure by
embers club where a rayfield driver
likes to kick it
there every friday night like clockwork
as soon as you appear
security cam shut down gate swings up
the road is yours
just gotta grab the rayfield and roll
out simple
how am i supposed to do this expect me
to slide under the chassis on a
skateboard for a quick hot wire
fast and easy kirk wheels like this got
security systems
good ones
this bitty bop works like the key
rayfield techs use for repairs
opens locks bypasses identity
authorization
a skeleton key for all ray fields in the
city
come on kirk even you don't buy that
kabuki's tech wizards sell more magical
[ __ ] than this
under the counter have a little faith
so we all agreed then
we are glad to hear it always said you
were a bright bulb
head to embers in the glen rick's in the
garage be waiting for you
you two will hit it off good luck out
there
be in touch
[Music]
is
hey why do i see no goddamn lemons
who do we have here we
long time didn't know you were around
got back from atlanta a few weeks ago
see you got a good dog
home welcome how was it like east
tell you later got something on my plate
how about you fill me in now
we'll give you a ride marcus let's go
the glenn drop me off at amber's
front door take the ramp back at the bar
show you where to stop you heard it
marcus
your return to nc has been good
busy already i pick up something here
and there
nothing major but i'm getting by
appreciate the concern so
i'd like to didn't turn out like you
expected huh
as you can see i'm back i've been better
there
wouldn't have left maybe it'll all work
out for the best
two two
[Music]
[ __ ]
stop the car what's going on
business you carry
sebastian ibarra looks like it's my
lucky day
what do you want to settle our biz
once and for all got an offer for you
patty
so listen up get the [ __ ] out of vista
pull your boys off the street
i'll give you the glenn done dale no
more restless nights
see how generous i can be
well patty one more [ __ ] word
stay out of this i don't know you and i
don't know you
which means you're with [ __ ] around here
and capable of even less
well anything else it seems our
conversation has come to a close
careful padre never know who's got a
barrel at your six
you neither [ __ ] bucket marcus please
i'm pleased to see you have nothing
still happening so many of the little
shits left around here
their spines were solved
[Music]
who was there no one important
he'll be gone in a week's time another
will come in his place
he pulled iron on you he did
and he will pay for doing so
pull up here right here i'll just drop
down below
here before you go
your number could be useful
maybe we can also work together again
take ourselves back two years
thanks padre gotta go
so go with god
i'll be damned
v status on location
about to find your man rick's one of the
good guys you'll see
i trust him like a brother
yeah someone i can help you with
kirk i see the ride your moment to shine
kiddo
good luck
[Music]
let's take this piece of wonder tech for
a whirl
you're a man of little faith see
we're rich now fire up and call me when
you're underway
tell you where to go
[Music]
looks like this will be a cool breeze
get the [ __ ] out
get the [ __ ] out
oh [ __ ] you can drive
you're where under arrest
heads where i can see him nice and slow
on the ground [ __ ] now
jackie wells my old pal from the hood
see you haven't grown an ounce white hey
detective stance been a while huh
inspectors
same [ __ ]
speaking of your mug's familiar too
yeah you think to me
left for atlanta looking for a slice of
happiness
yes you didn't find it i've always
maintained it's the same for all you
termites in haywood
born here live here die here
looks like i was right
you know [ __ ] all about me
truth hurts huh just watch your toe
i'm not a patient man come on stance
give us a break huh you lock us up
i just took off till trial and then what
worst case we get some months
standing room only nowadays
oh they'll probably be out early
are these the thieves 40 30 street trash
got him in custody mr fujioka we'll be
taking them now
it's a waste of effort i have no time to
testify or play it under investigation
suggesting we let them go sir i suggest
you toss them in the sea
cufflink's broken so this trash doesn't
float
you heard him [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ]
honestly for a sector things looked iffy
wasn't sure we'd worm out of that alive
and same stints is out to get people
wound tight but he does have a little
honor left
really think his sense of honor saved us
well
and the fact he's haywood born and bred
like us
if i hadn't come you'd be cruising night
city in sexy wheels right now
nah it was all my fault wait
what pigs didn't waddle in out of
nowhere
my tech must have triggered the alarm
so maybe now has got ordained
jackie wells v
i know you you hang at the coyote
got the job to steal those wheels at the
coyote from kirk
you work with that sewer slug pepe
wasn't big and can't afford to pay
so i stepped up
man gotta wonder about pepe letting
slimy kirk boss him around like that
heard what they say he's backed by
cartels
cartels no no listen i know those cartel
types
and i guarantee you none of them have
even heard of kirk
el cavon's gotta learn you don't do
people in here with dirty
come on let's go have some lunch
lunch you would not believe my mama's
chili
best in town
getting one of my good feelings about
what
about us this is the kind of chemistry
you know
come on i'm [ __ ] starved
okay food it is let's go
night city